because i got a question for you what is
it when
your baby's mommy when your baby's mama
buried her father
rest his soul he was cremated he's in
the living room
he's in the living room and make no
mistake when on saturday when
president-elect biden got announced on
cnn the urn
shook a little bit i thought there was
an earthquake yeah because he was just
he was trying to get out he was a puerto
rican kid who voted for trump big time
so did his daughter
did they uh did they put him in the uh
when they went to burnham what do they
call it and
they put him in a uh what it's called
like the the the oven yeah
yeah crematorium the creeper when they
put them in the uh
when they put them in the oven did they
did they put him in there with his maga
hat
and uh his handball yeah they did they
put him in there with his handball
because puerto ricans love a blue
ring and they put him on they put him in
there i was there they put him in they
had
he had his trump hat on they put his
hand ball and then the thing is with
puerto ricans it's just the l as the
last
act that you know uh uh my his my his
wife his ex-wife
you know my baby you know uh my girl's
uh mother
the last act like any puerto ricans you
know a puerto rican
thing was put in the oven so liz just
came in she sprinkled a little adobo on
the coffin and that was it
anything that goes to the os yeah they
just they just pick a little dough on
the body and that's
it that's it like if you're not from new
york city you don't understand
what a blue ball means to puerto ricans
yeah i mean what a blue ball is used for
is handball so what it is
you smack the ball against the wall yeah
that's what it is and puerto ricans
love nothing more than specifically
saturday or sunday with a case full of
[ __ ] budweiser yeah and a mess shirt
playing
handball in july a handball literally
they should change
it's it's puerto rican catnip that's
what a handball is
it's puerto rican a handball they
[ __ ] do whatever you say they just go
they [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah i can say that because got a puerto
rican kid yeah and you can we could also
say it because it's the truth
just the truth if you grew up in new
york city brooklyn you know that those
courts
were always dominated by porters because
because they were out early on a
saturday with a [ __ ] radio
and a cooler full of budweisers and they
were [ __ ] throwing that ball against
the wall but it is cuz and i'm proud
to have finally i'm proud to have
carried president donald trump's dream
of building a wall i [ __ ] did it we
did it because we built the wall it's
called patreon.com
bay ridge boys yeah that's the [ __ ]
wall baby guys our channel that's our
channel that's our channel do you know
how much content is there do you know
how much fun
the members of the matriarchy have on
the community board watching the videos
we release so much content if you love
our podcast and you want more
i mean at this point we've been a
podcast for over two years so you can go
back and binge
all the bonus content excuse me there it
is i'm having seltzer water
all the bonus content we've done since
then and every wednesday we do wepa in
the morning so we
recap our week and we recap it in the
middle of the week because we're the
hyenas
if you want to watch the morning show
the best morning show
wake up with the hyenas join the
matriarchy patreon.com bay ridge
voice weapon in the morning every
wednesday you get episodes early
lot of 14s posts his [ __ ] there
it's what it is and by the way our our
resident one of our resident physicians
we have two resident physicians here at
the historians dr andrew agus
uh covert is spiking you're basically
saying the two guys around called to
look at pictures of your dick to see
what's on it it's what it is cause so so
he's tweeted he's tweeted because he
just watched weapon in the morning
um so he just tweeted uh he just texted
me he said yani should wear that mask
when he eats
and his shirt should say just ate it not
just do it that's funny it's what it is
so
so ann dragos with [ __ ] shots from
the chat room i mean our fans are so
funny go to patreon.combatebridge but
yeah that's the i should be wearing a
mask only at dinnertime
yeah word